I know the game would you rather as far
as our fathers playing would you rather
no I really don't know the game I'm
quite familiar with the game I do not
know the game would you rather I've
never played it sounds interesting
though I'm definitely looking forward to
the awkward question that's gonna be the
best part bypass this one would you
rather we tell you about our sex life or
you tell us about your sex life well I
think just to make make our sex like
spicy made me hear about yours
it's funny because they act like we
never had sex would you rather have five
million dollars or know for sure that
your son's plush daughter will have a
happy marriage their whole lives so big
number is a real big number five million
yeah but they're gonna be up and down
just like everybody else so why I let
the money would you rather let us live
with you forever or you have to live
with us forever do you guys have cable I
would rather live with you forever would
you rather we never have kids and are
happy or to have kids and are miserable
it definitely can be miserable I think
I'd rather you be happy because if you
weren't happy with kids you wouldn't be
together for long those kids wouldn't be
happy either that's really deep Mickey's
a good brother a good dad good father
I'm definitely thrilled that we will be
joining forces to make this Union to
make this here you work kind of getting
to know each other right here today
all right thanks and your dad yeah yeah
[Music]